hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to pray so I need
supplies to be able to make med kits and
the only place that I can go is in here
because I need I need a lot of I need a
lot of plant life and not synthetic but
any natural stuff which means there's a
lot of guys that can blow up in here and
I want to save them so what I'm going to
do is oh I thought I unlocked it oh here
we go
activate sprinklers yeah that did
nothing
birdy then that's nice that guys still
over there walk all right so I got to
get in here and I got to not let anybody
blow up
where is everybody oh there they are
okay hi hello are you doing just gonna
zap you come at me bro okay whoa and
that'll put those guys under and then
they won't blow up easy is that
oh I've been spotted oh boy you're just
gonna get this guy oh wow what something
killed me ball boy well let me try that
again
oh you're stem stomping don't get caught
in that Oh got you okay so they're all
unconscious now cool cool so that means
I should be able to take care of this
guy with view clip claps um a thing oh
hey I can't take one more head I can't
take another hit Tom and I just you know
save oh boy oh yeah yeah yeah okay
they're not dead yet haha
objet okay this is the first time the
type an organism is broken containment
it happened before shortly after your
initial neural on tests you and Alex
fought about terminating the project
evacuating
but Alex insisted he could control the
situation that's when you began
implementing secret contingencies hiding
the plan for your army key videos the
January protocol your concerns have
proven to be correct ah
I am correct Am I whoo look at all the
fruit so with this fruit I can salvage
it it's not just for food although it is
good for food but I can salvage it and
can turn it into med kits because
there's so much of it so with all this
stuff I get to make what I need to make
so I'll be right back once I have
everything in order but now I should be
able to make enough med kits go outside
do the coral thing and not have to worry
about dying a horrible death because
I'll actually have her
so I'll be right back once I got all
that in order okay also I have a lot of
neural mods right now so I should I
should get some of these more basic
things which increase you know the sigh
hypose they just make items more useful
along with the physician one which makes
it easier to do that I get more psycho
scope things all that good stuff and
then yeh well I could get more of these
things I could there's a lot of things
here ooh there's a lot of things here
that are awfully cool I guess it doesn't
really matter now that they already
recognized me but maybe that's Andy oh
that's nice whoo ah I need to get
another nightmare scan but that's okay
on that one okay and also I'm gonna get
this one then I got a lot of health and
I can always make more neurologic now
because I have a thing so I'm going to
now go where I needed to go so I'll be
right back once more again okay so I got
what I need so I should be able to go
out there and do what I need to do I I
don't have a lot I don't have a lot of
med kits but I do have a lot of health
now up to 200 now and if I get more
neurons than I should be able to upgrade
that even further which is going to give
me real good and if I can get away with
taking damage than honest I should be in
good shape
maybe so either way I'm going to try to
get this coral scan because maybe that
sounds like something that I would want
to do this technology though I don't
know I think an apt word might be to say
that it's cursed because it's using
alien not technology it's not even using
alien technology it's using alien
biology if you can even call it that
because the Typhon I don't even know if
they're like of this universe I don't
even know what they really are I don't
think any of us actually do but for some
reason they're able to remap my brain
and maybe it's all to do with this
girl stuff but I got when I need it can
you open up for me now ho there you go
okay I believe so now I just got to go
down there and I just got to get this
[ __ ] small little no calm oh why
okay you know how let's get out alone le
whoa ow oh oh okay oh that's not good
coral no please can I just have this
please just give it to oh my god oh my
god oh my god [ __ ] hell
okay I'm out of here okay [ __ ] you hold
everything - yeah I know that is on the
right track
don't ask me how I know kind of your old
structure huh sigh lactic like
creativity up and down the length of it
like it's communicating that's weird
just one more to go there's one more
hardness oh [ __ ] rocks are the war may
not just bring so much of the company's
future on your own yes I was right to
ignore him we're good what's up cooking
get me no no no no no no no no no no you
just stay over there how about you drift
off into space forever that sound like
something you wanna do okay you do that
so I just got to get in here
earlier the coral note is right around
the corner so seems like some kind of
secret entrance there's a lot of
lightning that's probably not good oh
boy oh boy wait is it oh no this isn't
even the way in I remember this is where
I got this cubed Y maybe not hello hail
a discus down a cargo hey listen did you
order any replies for work order anyone
replying its
machine machine what does it do well I'm
not sure I was hoping that you could
tell me wait is this some kind of a joke
I'm busy
Darrin industrial design it right so I
thought you would know you obviously
don't understand what I do and I didn't
order any deployer replay ask somebody
in engineering I did I've been asking
everyone no one ordered it or knows
anything about it
weird well perhaps I can come down this
evening and take a look at it that's
great thanks Lane well that's so weird
how problem that's so weird because I've
seen Reploids everywhere in this game
and why does no one seem to threaten the
needle oh okay we're going to make a
fast flyby here oh I'm gonna wait here
no and that's not what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna do this number repair my suit up
just a little bit it so I can have armor
going into the summit oh boy but I know
I stopped uh oh wow reddit Oh
[Music]
they're lying ah
Oh excellent work all this one is
integrating the data you uploaded are
the telephone justice yen surreal and
worried what is there's some kind of
neural tripwire built into the car oh
Christ Morgan tipping to my office we
have to get your data upload it out
hurry wait a minute I have a funny
feeling that I'm being lied to and
there's a different reason why all this
is here there has to be a different
reason right I'm thinking what I think
now is that there must be like all of
this is fabricated and not all of this
like the the invasion or whatever even
though I think maybe that was
orchestrated but Morgan is fabricated
you know what I mean that whole concept
like it seems like Alex was there in
that little figment of memory with a
bunch of medical robots all around me
saying you know there was some problems
going on and I'm thinking I'm thinking
maybe I'm not the real Morgan after all
would you something that I fought hourly
on in the game I thought that maybe I
funky there was going to be something
guess I'm Domino's to upload the data Oh
get it integrated into the fabrication
plan for the new null wave device as
fast as possible mmm be careful the
typhoon will begin to sense our intent
to harm the coral they're gonna come
after you mm-hmm thanks for your on my
desk that should help okay all right
sure okay oh yeah oh yeah I believe you
now what I don't know
hmm so I gotta get Alex who's arming
ki-woo so I gotta get that somehow I
don't think I have the fabricator
planned about yet unless I do I don't
know how to check unless I go to a
fabrication thing I'm wondering it's
going to be very bad if I do upload this
you know like cataclysmically bad then I
can't change anything you know what I
mean
I'm just curious just curious oh no Mon
Thank You anti rad oh that's awful oh
these are nice we need this flyby and
drop stuff up for me that's awfully nice
I suppose but also why okay whatever
so utilities repair looking-glass
oh well that oh that's handy I'm glad
they put a button in for that
hey y'all okay EP 101 upload coral scan
I don't know if I want to do this but
I'm just going to see cuz I can't make
any assumptions before I do this
Oh Casper Gloria press was holding
something for someone this is commander
rorke ago the Johnstown Board of
Directors has authorized me to take full
command of Carlos 1 no effective degree
Oh boys must now report to the shuttle
bay for evacuation but why I was about
to blow everything SOS and my team of
rescue operators will locate you I like
American Alex and more than you have
been relieved of their positions do not
consent to their requests or a system in
any way
bail out
oh well that seems bad oh hi
are you friendly whips - okay cool boy
ow
quite cool there we go Hotel Delta right
there oh I'm going to be charitable and
a scuffle with it - and didn't just
break it out of me I'm in a battle here
oh hey I'm in a freakin fight to the
death got [ __ ] military operators all
over the place
do you not my fault oh well locked out
his stall he already has his hooks into
every major system aboard tell us one
hmm to admit I'm disappointed with our
parents and you really had a contingency
in place but a small foolish part of me
believed I wouldn't use him against our
own flesh and blood
hmm regardless we're not getting this
coral data through until we do something
about it I don't like it but you're
gonna have to get into this command
shuttle see if you can locate his access
point in cut him off okay that doesn't
seem very family-friendly I'm thinking
that there's gonna be some regrets about
that later on can I just get your arming
key and blow this all up because I don't
like being lied to
where am I going where is this command
shuttle alex is hiding until Dahl and
his tech officer are delayed disabled
okay but where are they Oh down there oh
I must need to get down to the Arboretum
or the main lobby oh no no no no why
yah-yah-yah your doll will know you're
coming huh all trans star personnel are
outfitted with tracking bracelets I have
no doubt his operators are already on
their way
what the [ __ ] God why is everything
lightning
what does everything have to be
lightning [ __ ] man
here we go here we go no no no shortcut
shortcut shortcut la la la la la
ok you're good go go go go go
let's go ok either way we got to get
down to this command shuttle that we got
to take care of this [ __ ] because
there's something fishy going on here
and they took over and I don't want to
be dealing with all that right now I
want to be dealing with what I got in
front of my face so they can just do
that for me I would be very happy
oh boy doll will know you're coming
I know doll will know I'm coming Orson
LR outfitted with tracking bracelets
yeah I have no doubt his operators are
already on their way to rescue you
oh those bracelets are issued and
removed in deep storage what worth
investigating if you want to fly I was
oh come on I was just buying storage oh
no no I will not give you up you were
there for me I am yeah Oh what what why
are you [ __ ] [ __ ]
god damn it I didn't even get out the
goddamn door you [ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
don't come on go go faster now what are
you just free there don't calm darlin
till we got a chance to speak in person
oh all right fine I'm coming up to you
I'm coming up to you I'm coming up to
you
[ __ ] hell I just stand by the goddamn
door hi
what is it Morgan I was worried Allah
his rescue team had intercepted you AMC
and nine black box operators not a
rescue team rescue is not among the list
of commands not now
yes of course but does his arrival may
help us as long as you have not killed
him you see now he's a recipient of
several neuro mods and standard array of
combat tactics interrogation mods as I'm
sure you know your father the board is
very thorough doctor anyway please
present your conclude
to Morgan bigger if there is a point uh
well yes you see does mother early see
series beta vulnerable Assoc has
old-school thinking on some matters we
remove them you may forget his mission
here yet we would still have access to
the shuttle and the way home provided
his pilot acknowledged renamed intact
the risk but worth taking I think well
he'll have to be some dude of course
afraid that task force to you like it no
one else alive on the station who can
pilot the shuttle I can do it worth the
time mmm-hmm I can do it I'd rather not
kill people
iPhone by under stimulation for free
links a microphone normally the tests
are only a few days long because resists
even though he's hiding hmm you are
running around like a nervous wreck you
don't know about here you chewing the
wires I'm cheating in the wall well
that's where you're you're trying to fix
the mess you've made or just get away
walk okay I pride myself in being
prepared for the worst but this this is
truly a masterpiece you should be proud
I feel like you're mocking me and I
don't really know who you are so that's
a little rude of you so if you could
just not do that that'd be absolutely
great okay so I need to get rid of booth
and blue house man that's about all I
can do I'm keeping this I don't care
I need to get that eventually one of the
side missions that I wasn't able to do
are you doing there are you cowering in
the corner okay
he always has a back-up plan uh-huh mark
mas you don't know you don't know that
he might not okay so I'm gonna need more
disruptor because I'm gonna stun him I'm
gonna need to disrupt her to be able to
do that I'm gonna take that right there
and then I'm gonna head out rockin y'all
I'm gonna disrupt him and then remove
his neural mod now how you
on us sounds weird
okay I don't liked it I like this whoa
I'm gonna go with will quo okay made it
alright apparently can I go through here
unlock okay I'm gonna go the shuttlebay
because apparently that's easier to do
yeah he's gonna know I'm coming though
Oh also I don't know why it's so hard to
remove a tracking bracelet like just why
wouldn't you be able to just do it why
don't you take it off is it embedded in
your skin or something maybe for
security reasons they wouldn't want
people to take those off but oh well
muskan Adil on in here and I'm gonna fan
and why okay there's a lot of things
there time for me to go incognito
alright
[Music]
la la la I'm very slow wah wah
auntie they ordered a Hilda dating
lottery [ __ ] out leverage Morgan oh man
thank God
I've just been going down the contact
list hoping somebody would answer I'm in
trauma center I came up here to look for
supplies I think I broke my arm when
that blackout happened now I'm trapped
aliens outside the door I can really use
some help no I can't help you I don't
know what you're talking about but I
have no idea where you are how to help
you go I think that you are on your own
dama would be able to go through that
door but I can't lift that I don't have
enough leverage and I don't do I have to
know mom's to be able to get leverage oh
I might I've got 500
you need six ah ah ah okay you know what
I'm just gonna go for it Frick you know
key card for the employee entrance about
the bathroom
something in here that I can use we some
organic material would be nice maybe I
could just salvage a bunch of [ __ ] and
not be able to make the med kits out of
that by some weird logic then I'm not
going to dive too deep into maybe that's
bad idea
well we sign get these flowers we didn't
need to shoot that I forgot that I don't
have a melee Hiskey handle but again I
think they want to donate to the salvage
yard no no all right fine
flying down the middle huh I can do that
I've got magical powers look how all
those turrets got damn it [ __ ] things
are everywhere okay new operator but I
should be able to sneak by if I use my
stealthy aw okay nevermind i ran out of
- why what's the point please stand
clear
oh boy oh boy oh boy Oh cat damage
complete well that went about as bad as
it could complete it okay well that's
not good
[ __ ] me womp it won't be playing okay
good god what is the point of that
requesting new operator okay well I ran
out of power don't go okay I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go oh my god I should have bow
and favor before I went like an idiot
then I just ran out in the middle
Cartman don't ask me why I did that or
why I thought that was a good idea I
just panicked because the thing was
about to pump out a new operator and
then I don't know what happened but it
was very tough oh why don't you just be
dead you [ __ ] at all oh my god let me
just open to that can you guys tell can
you guys tell can you tell okay okay oh
come on come on we're fine we're fine
everything's fine everything's fine
everything's fine oh my god Oh where do
I gotta go where do I gotta go the guy
gotta go right down the middle
nope yeah okay we're outta here now oh
okay we're down here hello can take your
stuff got a wrench fabrication plan
that's what I needed
Annie I know you'll never eat this I ran
on my office when I heard you screaming
but there were too many of them between
you and me you were always really nice
to me you didn't deserve to die like
that and now they're in my office and
I'm surrounded out here in this cage I
can't help myself much less you or even
Mia even when I try still screw things
up I'm sorry that's depressing I got the
shuttle control room key card which is
good I guess it's going to be useful I
think
oh man those a blind panic start to
finish
okay let me say because I'm a relatively
good place and if I can just use my
goddamn armor kits was gonna be chilly
enough and we should be okay and I don't
know where I need to go but I'm gonna go
here somewhere hello
unlock that looks good
little fabricator no salvager almost as
good not quite as good but you know kind
of good oh oh yeah got more stuff get a
pistol done then I have no organic
material like organic material something
that actually very very sparse around
here I don't know I not sure why it's so
sparse it just seems like something that
would be a little a little less rare oh
well they just can't be choosers and I'm
just gonna have to do what I can with it
we're almost to where we need to go okay
here who did that who do you think you
are oh hi okay alright then I don't know
if I want to unlock that you're just
saying I don't think I want to unlock
that that seems like a room of dad where
does this go
he told me there was another entrance
just right here all into the guts I
didn't know that you could go into the
guts from here that would have been
smart for me to actually do that but
then again I like the charge blindly
into the fray down there that I could
get woo radiation whoa who's what the
[ __ ] when I get no alert that I was
being lasered this is like Oh casual
lasering oh yeah that's no problem
damnit okay I gotta get up there but his
command shuttle is up high I'm down low
how in the hell we get from God - ah
[ __ ] [ __ ]
come on try oh how to get I'm just gonna
go is fighting him soon could be a good
point good point I'm gonna go in here
the best I can do oh I don't want to do
this but I got nothing
I don't I've got a whole lot of nothing
I'm gonna do recycler charge oh that's
not what I'm into
did that work well it didn't work it
almost worked
Oh Harry never go okay well alright then
where did Connie go whoa I don't know
where the corpse went but okay this
corpse lost stuff in here anyway that's
good okay and what do we have utilities
Oh grab shaft whoa okay operator
deployment
all right there we go please [ __ ]
nightmare that was I still don't know
why the voltaic one's corpse wind
because I'm all they're just not that
okay so I turned on the graph shaft hey
I don't know what problems you got going
on and honestly I don't care to get your
work done on time because you're holding
me back Annie I lied to you the other
day when I asked if I was okay I'm not
there's something wrong with me but I
don't know what it is I don't need that
I'm tired all the time I feel like [ __ ]
the only thing I want to do is sleep and
even then I get all I get are nightmares
I went to see dr. Sol de Silva but she
said there wasn't anything physically
wrong with me wanted me to see dr. Cole
but I could no I know Frank would just
give me [ __ ] if you found out I was
talking to a shrink anyway I don't know
why I'm telling you this you've always
been nice to me I guess maybe I just
wanted someone to remember me after
Lowell JIT KK what the [ __ ]
Oh God oh it's so sad
is that the same guy who was outside one
so what's with this drawing looks like a
Typhon dragon Oh weird there's something
in the locker room here what's in here
why was there an objective in here what
is this all this is weird okay
okay okay I don't know why why does that
say there's multiple objectives right
there that's so weird
I've no oh here no here no what now are
you talking about then god I have no
idea okay
either way I can keep going nice mad kid
which is awfully nice
I don't seem to get any more of those I
can get a leverage oh nice on fabricator
which is going to be very useful what is
it said whoever keeps making duplicate
items stop fabricator is not a toy
materials are not unlimited
yeah you're goddamn right I need more of
them but okay at least I can make some
shotgun shells
cuz I'm running low on there my favorite
shootie shoot it's running low like
unique not good enough regular charge
maybe
that's it for me I gotta get going that
was all that was in here I guess it was
just some bonus item so nothing really
scrap shaft was talked about I don't
understand how to get up there more than
I already have
I got it there's got to be some way to
lower that down oh is that like a
control room up there I did get a
keycard for that oh my god I'm walking
in the middle of everything I didn't
even realize oh my god oh my god oh hey
hi everybody
hello didn't mean for this happen oh
this is a mistake
hi okay Crab Shack look whoa ah dead
body
great okay so I've somehow gone in here
and I didn't mean to go in here so I'm
just gonna oh I'm gonna unlock this just
kids are fall out whoo okay we did that
now I'm gonna go off the grass yeah wait
I think this is what I needed to do but
somehow I did it before I needed to know
that I needed it okay but kind of oh hi
Typhon oh boy oh let's get out of here
okay made it walking home hi okay hi how
you doing I made it in here I don't know
how I don't know why I need to repair
huh blind panic all the way
oh yes something just was right in front
of you yeah didn't know one more please
long very slow bump it's there all right
okay I know I lost one more flight was
uneventful recovered highly unusual but
then got really strange captain spotted
first a facility out there and he was
running dark a facility where what we
were too far away to see any details but
it was big cooper snapped into action
punched in the course for Talos and
fired the engines why Tristan drifting
vessel identified as a military vessel
received a radio message cam goober what
there was a facility out there oh that's
so weird why was there a facility out
there that was not Hallows one that's
super strange no idea we've had enemy
contact but the enemy there should've
his position in the cargo bay I couldn't
chief I couldn't let those people and
you get to the escape pods negative the
escape pods are malfunctioning it's like
they're locked in place only four of us
made it to life of five
I'm picking up Rimmer behind you
negative Rimmer Rimmer isn't Remer chief
these things cheap okay all right I'm
done there I've been thinking about what
you've done what you're doing
we all must act according to our nature
no matter what the psychologists and
priests say in your nature I think I was
right before you I like a rat okay again
with the rats I'm okay yeah yeah all
right third and he's a kind of
of mine okay thank you yeah something
was over in the laboratory and the
experiment was a failure mmm of course
sadly you know what happens to the rats
when they are no longer needed when our
rats needed in the first place your see
your allegory there doesn't really make
a lot of sense I just I feel like you're
lost a nun uncertain about what you're
talking about so let me say extend
jetway ah but it's too high flight
systems check
oh that's how you do it okay all systems
nominal so what I need to do is I need
to get in there and I need to beat the
[ __ ] out of them with the stun gun
because that's what I'm prepared to do
I'll do that I'm gonna do it I'm gonna
do that I'm gonna do that hello open up
Dingaan wah wah hello
anybody in here they want to get zapped
you know where yeah buddy yeah buddy
booth where are you buddy
where you at what's going on here look
at all this food in here living in the
lap of luxury you are thanks take those
so why please wait are you in here huh I
can't get in there doubt cargo-hold know
if he's in there where he is
guess he wouldn't be on his shuttle I
guess I wouldn't make a lot of sense
oh here we go
files uh Security Elevens Alpha Sigma
mission parameters ok ok
command at all this is William you
acting chairman of the trans now Board
of Directors they will need your
credentials to authorize this mission of
course my authentication sign is Zeta
Invictus Emperor tangerine sign checks
out
good morning director you shuttle is hot
sand holding orbits awaiting mission
parameters
you must secure every piece of cobalt
clearance level technology and research
a boy Talos one then eliminate all trans
star personnel all personnel no
survivors it's your show and their
funeral payment will be deposited into
six separate Benelux accounts after you
transmit evidence of success as if my
operator feeds on just keep watching we
strongly advise deploying your technical
officer to a station router inside the
firewalls first ideal site would be in
the neural margin yes I've seen the
schematics mister you goodbye you will
destroy the transmission up oh we didn't
know ok so there's a security officer
somewhere in the neural mud to be I need
to go over there this was a lot of
fighting these two get a little bit over
there
Oh Ricky's ok ok bang oh great great
wonderful
come at me where you at I'm ready for
you you know what I'm just gonna go for
it the other way that I found it's gonna
be all laser how how we okay you know
why we made it out of here and we can
get out of here because we need to go to
neuro mods oh oh it's just a nightmare
everywhere you go how would anybody be
expected to kill everything in here it's
so horrible
anyway I got to get to neuro mod that
means I got to go back to where I
originally was yeah somewhere in the
beginning of the game whyever they were
doing these tests I don't know I don't
know nothing I just do what I'm told I'm
probably gonna end up blowing up
everything but why does he want to kill
one with my heart hidden as an HR
expensive it's awful
I do some people problems
yeah your workmates hiding in the cargo
bay are going to suffocate in a few
minutes huh maybe you can say that what
you'll have to come out of the walls rap
world life support the clock is ticking
well oh god oh god oh god what do you
wanna meet cargo bay oh no oh God none
of the doors are responding four
controls are in life support what if you
can help do it quick boy this is the
last time what we talk hey I got hang on
Oh
I was right to be a doll is manipulating
the oxygen in our home with nitrogen
flooding into the Amazon cargo bay will
asphyxiate far more quickly simply I
suspect it already so we're trying to
use them to manipulate you okay well
does that mean I need to go to life
support or what ah okay I need to uh Oh
like I do need to go to like support
okay I feel like saving people because
that seems like the right thing still
has everything got to be so horrible all
the time oh all right what do we got
pocket suck
oh my god that was so hard and why is it
such a long delay just to get out of the
goddamn deep oh boy okay
whatever it's fine I'm fine everything
is fine so long as we can get in here
and get out in enough time we should be
okay and I'll save them I'll go up to
neural mod kick the science officers ask
this has just been one blinding like
spurt through the beginning and up yes
[Music]
uh-huh yeah okay whatever you say man
whatever you say
housing okay good guy got kind of an
[ __ ] you know what I'm just gonna go
for it so I can sir me Oh what is
happening down there I'm just gonna
skate aren't I roll that's gonna skate
on by don't mind me come on Tina oh I'm
going to get some suit repair in here
hey oh god more of you [ __ ] okay
alright let's gonna slide into club well
that was a bad slide Oh Frick okay okay
where am I going where am I going Harmon
I need to go oxygen flow control dowel
dollars right there hey what the [ __ ]
this is my private space
oh god oh god ow ow ow ow ow
there we go one down oh [ __ ] okay so
Dowell is somewhere up there if I can
just pull his freaking arming chip or
his neural mods out that he should be
should be easy to get but I just need a
good dog
oh my god they're so fast Oh bullski
whoa got one of them wait no that's not
what I wanted whoa
Frick this shadow okay god I'm down okay
those are down oh no no no are you
ditched class oh boy I'm doing it but
deny what cost
what okay this okay so I got to go get
down and I got a sample that's just what
I got to do
where is he he is slightly up above oh
hey okay
I gotta save enough vApp to be able to
get him that's what I gotta do
oh I can use another recycler charge
well I made it easy alright thank you
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you so he is
we're in there okay all right okay all
right I'm down I'm down to clown done
play
what's this hacking for I can get hacked
in before canta I have enough no romance
Oh again why am I always one-off oh I'm
always one oh god damn it there's got to
be another way in there it just has to
be right
has to be what is this console fan
controls check fans oh it looks pretty
lockdown fan 3 Jam and interrupt I don't
know what this gonna do ooh Jam maybe I
can get in that way well maybe maybe
baby oh there's something Oh Oh aah
ok so what if what is it super me well
good was that but it was jammed but I
interrupted it so that's ah come on
oh you're stupid lasers you don't look
cool you know don't look cool they
organized this thank you and the goes
then check fans in ski doing good okay
all fans okay here so what should I do
about that
still can't get in there not aim it okay
so there's Audi away that'd be a way for
me to give one mourner Aman but also Oh
God Morgan there's almost gone please
kill that sociopath acquired I'm working
on it I'm working on it don't worry I'm
working on it oh I got to figure out how
to get in here was this bad much good
ooh ski anything an air nope this is the
way around skadoosh game okay what's in
here nope that's not what I'm looking
for
it's gotta be something else utilities
initiate decontamination formation hi
okay so what did that do okay so what
did that do what do I do about that
Oh oh wait what
who oh okay
okay jeez I didn't know I did that other
is transport with a medical operator
then we can see about removing his neuro
MOT and hopefully gaining is subtle in
the process okay I didn't understand
what was happening
oh that was weird okay all right then
well hahaha okay all right - cn9 lockbox
operator ready to deploy so how do I get
over there now I stopped to get in there
how do I get in I can't I still can't
get in
oh how do I do that no wait oh it's that
easy
oh there's but there's a freaking window
and that that's how easy it is okay
alrighty then how about I just tell you
oh I can fix this okay boink and take
that put it in there okay
oh my god okay we did it there we go
easy simple Morgan the hair's flowing
again I can breathe and I hope this
means done Kent thank you a little
longer and never mind
hey let's all out okay whatever you say
you don't need to be so dramatic about
it so what have I got to do do I get a
carry Amir no there's no way I got to
carry him all the way over there they
said they were gonna get medical
transport arranged and then that means
contact oh yes again really oh oh this
is it isn't working
we're locked out oh my gosh River
Runners here stay away
Toa
geek America respond well apparently
Remer didn't want to play nice so I
don't know about that it was pretty
cut-and-dried it was okay so I got to
get up back up to my office I think it's
where I'm going to go because that would
be the logical place where I would meet
them and then hopefully that means we're
going to have a person to take us out of
here which is what we need to be able to
survive this mess I don't even know if
survivals on the menu but anything's
better than being here and I know that
if I go up that elevator that I'm going
to be warmed with a bunch of [ __ ]
as per yuge but maybe I could do maybe I
could just like kind of crouched down
maybe they won't see me like you know I
can't even crouch any or great good well
here we go blindly walking into death
again once more
[Music]
there we go oh boy oh boy oh boy
now Alan ready for the owl oh wow
there's the oh use active [ __ ]
why did you make it like that why oh my
god okay
hello smoking hooked up some more
supplies take what you need and don't be
shy about using I don't think they will
where where did you get more supplies I
don't see anything
oh well I seem to be full of [ __ ]
here okay this is fine everything's fine
everything's good like that awesome
cuz I'm not supposed to come here where
am I supposed to go where's the where's
the objective action takes me to the
trauma center or something save Ronny
Tex officer wait for further
instructions
well that's not gonna help me that's not
gonna help me at all
alright fine then because that is what
it is I came up here for knows always I
wonder if doll is worth you license Josh
be a mourner Amma's while your thought
out and his life signs are stable thank
you we are prepping him in the new
remote division now come as soon as you
can oh I needed to go the nermal
division anyway Gordon would you go was
spreading to other parts of the station
I never eat - they're just going to keep
building it indefinitely it must have
some end purpose uh-huh okay alright
then so I need to go the neural model
and meet them there which is super cool
and something not happy about okay yes
[Applause]
okay I can do this okay fine
oh it's fine dilly dally dilly dally
dilly dally that would be nice Oh can't
make that okay here we go goodnight
marathon here to be able to be able to
believe it everybody brew okay we're
good yes and this is crazy run around
they got me going around here
she's like a frantic sprint from start
to finish this whole episode it's been
nothing but chaos Oh Frick but we're
okay for now anyway I'm shocked I
haven't died that much I mean in the
beginning I died a bit too but uh my god
talk about the climax of the story here
okay come on anything it now I know the
knurl Monty is a very impressive place
but whoa okay okay oh I'm just gonna you
wrap on there talk exactly what I mean
to the frickin sprint oh come on Howie
huh I got something for the simulation
lab some key code I don't know what but
I got it okay it's gotta sneak by Neal
still loaded with it well I need to go
oh boy I think I'm good
oh I made so many goose come on
server arks s 32 and 37 crit okay okay
doors are working again Morgan nice work
okay I did it what's left of my crew to
the atmosphere control is in life
support okay we're going to clear out
that [ __ ] Kent operators and make sure
there are no more mishaps with the air
on this station okay thanks
how populated his entire crew with
customized operators you made a mistake
of hanging his hopes on the machine yes
your flesh and blood is messy Morgan but
it's the only thing that matters in the
end
okay yes sir okay what did you do that
your algorithm we have important work to
do oh not that way whoa how do I get out
of here again I've done liver gun it's
been so long I think through here okay
good god oh my God my god Oh bash again
[ __ ] I want your [ __ ] I'll pull your
guts out
also they given me a lot of QB mammals
so I might as well use the QB because
I've got oodles of it oh look I knew
there was a good reason for me home this
thing around here man hurry up
I ain't got all day okay there we go Oh
oh my god well that's shockingly
effective okay all right then what is
that for
control panel for what grab shaft oh
good see there's the second floor all
right well for the best here whoo
they're all dead good sign oh that's a
good thing
oh that's a good sign
Wow nailed it okay so anyway that is all
the time I got for this episode we are
rapidly approaching the end of this game
but we're not quite there yet we still
have the ultimate decision to make so
thank you everybody so much for watching
I hope you enjoyed this wild ride of an
episode and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]